( INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC PLAYING )
My father would drive me out.
He was-- incidentally,
my father was sometimes here,
sometimes not here.
He was really gone from the time
I was about four...
but he'd show up from time
to time and take me out
for a ride...
in the car with the rumble seat.
But we'd drive out towards
Newark Airport, and it was
called Shantytown...
and there would be a couple
of acres of tents.
And you'd see little bonfires...
and the- there were men
who had left their homes...
or they couldn't support
their families.
And they weren't vagrants,
because they lived there.
And these were people
who didn't have any money.
And they had shame.
There was a lot of shame!
The um, the Depression,
if there's another word
to use to describe it...
was--
it was fraught with shame.
Times were so bad uh.. at uh..
for everybody. And so we were
no different.
Uh.. I remembered one time my
mother said to my father-- he
was a cab driver--
"There's no milk on the table.
Why don't you go out and hack,
bring in some money?"
He says, "Nobody's getting in
taxis these days. They can't
afford it."
She says,
"Go out. Hold up a bank!"
My father went out; a- an
hour-and-a-half later, he threw
a quarter on the table.
He said, "Here, buy some milk,"
and he started to cry.
And my mother would sit there
and look at him some day, uh..
watching- watching him
smoke a cigar.
She said, "Who do you think you
are with a cigar? Rockefeller?"
She came over
and she broke the cigar.
From that point on,
my father smoked a pipe.
All comedy comes out of tragedy.
Which is, you know, it's a
shock! It's a uh.. a social
shock.
And it's a terrible thing
for people to just have the rug
pulled out.
But that's when human
creativity sprouts.
It's forced.
"Have to do something
about this!" Gotta eat!
So where do we start""
They used to say uh.., "My
father couldn't work."
That was the-- they called that
stock lines.
Everybody used the same line.
"He couldn't work. There was no
food in the house.
We couldn't pay the rent. And
the landlord was going to
dispossess us,"
and then came the Depression.
And people laughed.
It was created from that period.
NARRATOR: New York, October,
1929. Everything was calm and
peaceful in this great city.
Then suddenly the bottom
dropped out of Wall Street.
But were the brokers
discouraged? No!
They knew prosperity was just
around the corner.
Some preferred white bread.
Some whole wheat.
Others rye.
The birds had little choice.
I was born an orphan.
I didn't have any home...
so I was one of the kids who
grew up coming out
of absolute poverty.
I didn't have any future. I
didn't know what I wanted to be.
So I started hitchhiking across
the country to see what would
happen.
This was in 1929.
In June, 1929.
And I hitchhiked up the coast
to Walla Walla, Washington...
and then I wanted across the
Rockies, and that was tough on
hitchhiking...
so I started becoming a hobo
on railroads.
I rode freight trains across the
country, always kept going.
I had no money whatsoever
with me. Maybe five dollars.
And uh.. every time there
was a job offered, I took it...
whether I knew what to do
with it or not.
Two bucks a day for this.
All I have to do is walk up and
down, turn the light on and off.
This your regular job?
No, no, I don't believe
in regular jobs. I do this
for a friend of mine.
I sub for him on his night off.
And all you gotta do is walk up
and down here?
That's all.
Is it all right if I walk
up and down with ya?
Sure. It's a free country,
ain't it?
I got to New York.
I was sleeping in the YMCA gym
in Brooklyn, and there was a job
open as a typist.
And I was on Wall Street,
and I was working away at it
every day in August and July.
And then along came October.
And this was a great turning
point in my life.
On October 29th, 1929, the
Depression, the Great Depression
started.
And they couldn't keep up
with the way the markets were
falling, the prices changing.
You couldn't sell your stock
even if you wanted to, and you
knew it was going down...
'cause you couldn't the-- you
couldn't get the thing, the
message through.
Everything was jammed. The uh..
the people in the office...
at the National City Bank of New
York where I worked...
were all crying because they'd
all invested all of their
savings in a-- on Wall Street.
Wherever you looked, boys and
girls were-- uh...
men and women were wondering
what was ever going to happen
to them.
And I was wondering a little
about it, but I was wondering
that since the time I was born..
so I had an advantage
over the rest of them.
Narrator:
Contending with modern economic
difficulties...
requires quite as high courage
and as much enterprise...
as was were displayed by men
and women of covered wagon
days.
I was born in Brooklyn, New
York, on a boarding house
table...
and my f- father had come from
Glasgow, Scotland, was in the
First World War...
and he became a comic.
And um, I stayed in uh...
in burlesque at the time.
Uh.. the people wanted to laugh.
There was nothing to laugh
about, and uh.. they got
together and said,
"Let's have a burlesque show."
Said, "What's that?"
"Just gags and- and uh.. dance
group and this and that."
My mother brought me
to California.
She uh.. in a broken down car
and uh.. she said...
"I've got a feeling my son
wants to be something."
So we traveled and we-- there
were no motels or anything.
We slept on dirty, dirty
mattresses.
It wasn't easy, and uh.. no
roads, no maps.
"Are we on the way to
California?" "Ah, I think it's
down that way."
You know, that-- it was rough
on my mother.
I remember being born.
So, I have a total recall of all
of my life.
When I was 19 years old, I went
to the Greyhound bus...
to get on the bus, and looked
in the United Cigar Store
window...
and there was a copy of a book
there called, "Grapes of Wrath"
by John Steinbeck.
I bought "The Grapes of Wrath,"
got on the bus...
and rode through the Dust Bowl
on Highway 66...
reading about it in the book.
The book was something.
And Steinbeck spoke to me. So
when I wrote "The Martian
Chronicles,"
I borrowed the ideas
for "The Martian Chronicles"
from "The Grapes of Wrath."
I remember trying to think about
how I could take my bicycle...
and how I could put some wings
on the sides of it...
and maybe get a little bit
of lift as I pedaled along.
And of course, I built cockpits
out of uh.. orange crates...
and- and cans and things that
resembled a throttle...
and here I'd never even been
in an airplane...
but- but it was
uh.. a kinda make believe.
And in those days you
listened to "The Shadow"
and "The Creaking Door."
And you- you didn't have the
imagination stolen from you...
by the visuals of television;
you had to imagine all these
things.
The- the thing that uh.. was
amazing about the times that
we'll never see them again...
was that people were, in my
opinion, heroically passive.
They just took whatever life
handed them.
They obeyed the law as much as
possible, except when it came to
feeding their families.
Then they would steal or they
would do anything that they had
to do to survive.
I remember stealing food
to bring home.
I remember looking behind uh..
the m- markets or garbage cans
looking for- for like-
like head- head of lettuce that
still had some good leaves on.
Uh.. you know, uh...
we did those things to stay
alive. And uhm.. my father took
off.
My- my mother remarried and uh..
had a stepfather who was the
kind of--
had that kind of ethic that the
man worked, you know, the woman
cooked, the man worked.
And, there was no work.
There was no work, and that
impacted on him, and he turned
just vicious, um...
suffering from that.
So the whole family unit
suffered in so many ways.
The Great Depression of the
1930s is not just another
commodity bubble...
or price bubble. It's- it--
the reason it was so deep
and lasted so long...
is because there was a
convergence of so many things
happening.
There was the- the great bubble
of stock prices, of course,
in the 1920s...
and that's because of the stock
market crash.
But we've seen stock market
crashes of kind of comparable
proportions...
without the ensuing great
economic chaos...
so there's something more and
deeper at work here in the
1930s.
And uh.. to be honest about
it...
economic historians do not agree
to this day about exactly what
happened.
I remember when the banks closed
in '32, and- and uhm..
my mother called my brother and
me in-- we were all playing in
the yard, and she said,
"I have bad news." And I thought
maybe a cherished relative had
died or something.
And- and she said, "The banks
have closed, and you will not
see the money...
that you have in the bank
anymore, because we'll probably
never get it back."
We didn't have Social Security.
We didn't have a lotta the
things that people have today
to, you know...
to guide them through rough
times.
So it was uh.. I mean,
you were totally on your own.
I was, guess about 11 year
old...
1936 when lotta people came to
California from Oklahoma...
in that, you know,
the Dust Bowl.
But growing up in the area, uh..
we like some of our friends,
we'd like to say, "We were poor,
but we didn't know it," 'cause
everybody was poor.
I think maybe the Okies made it
because of sheer
determination...
but if you didn't have any
money, you didn't have a car or-
uh..
how we you gonna make that move?
It was too tough.
Although I do know one family
who uh.. who made it very
successfully in Canada...
and they told me stories of how
they piled I think five of six
kids...
the mother and the father in the
car with all their early
belongings...
with frying pans still hanging
from the sides of the car,
just like they Okies did.
And they stopped off in little
places and eventually, uh..
one son was deposited in Regina,
another one in Saskatoon,
another one in Calgary.
Uh.. they each tried to make
their own way in various parts
of Canada.
It was, you know, Charles
Dickens once wrote, said,
"It was the best of times; it
was the worst of times." Believe
me, it was the worst of times.
People were walking around
without eating.
And there's no need to talk
history of what happened in
terms of the very famous...
rich, who, you know, what
happened to them.
But the- the real--the real--
you felt like the country was
going down, you know?
We lost our house in 1933 and
were thrown out on the street.
And uh..
it certainly is one of
the most awful moments of my
life ever.
And my father
was not a worldly man.
Who, when everybody was making
money in the stock market, and
everybody was--
and people were saying, "Gee,
Joe, what-- where-- what do you
do with your money?" "I got it."
He was keeping it in the house,
hidden. And they said, "You
know, that's crazy.
Your house can burn down. Invest
it." Well, he didn't know, so he
invested in 1928.
I think he invested in Electric
Bond and Share and Anaconda
Copper.
And of course, he bought on the
margin, as everybody did.
Uh.. I mean, that's what they--
they thought that was the way to
do it...
and they were encouraged to do
it by the brokers.
And uh.. when everything
collapsed, we lost everything,
and then we uh.. my father
was never the same man.
And we were having lunch, and a
man that they knew...
the man at the bank who handled
the mortgages came in, and he
said,
"What're you people doing here?"
And my mother said-- I'm not
going to mention his name...
because he still has family in
Wilkesboro-- and my mother said,
"Mr. X, we're having our lunch.
Would you like to sit down and
have something to eat?"
And he said, "You can't have
lunch here. This is not your
house. This is my house!"
My father just-- by this time,
was just gone.
And my mother said-- my mother's
a very strong woman, very brave
woman-- and she said, uh..
she said, "Well, Mr. X, uh..
it's our house. We live here.
It's our house."
He said, "Look, it's not your
house!" And he went-- And he
spit on the rug.
And with that, I mean, everybody
just coll-- the family just
collapsed...
and we were herded out of the
house. Our f- furniture was
taken out.
Everything was taken out of the
house and put on the street.
Most of which disappeared
shortly thereafter.
We went-- my mother had a
sister, who was married
to a- a very decent man...
who was an old socialist and
didn't believe in the stock
market or, you know...
profiting by anybody else's
labor.
He had a small furniture store
in West Pittston,
Pennsylvania...
and uh.. we went to live
with them.
I grew up in the Depression,
but when you have nothing to
contrast it with...
and all your neighbors are
living the same way...
you don't know you're in a Great
Depression, or even a mild
Depression.
But one of our saving graces--
and I think this is true of many
people around that time...
in a rural or a semirural area,
we had a very big garden which
was twice as big as our house...
and we raised a whole lot
of uh.. vegetables.
And so all summer we're living
out of the garden, and uh..
in a sense,
food is free in that way.
Uh.. we raised chickens. We had
uh.. 25 chickens.
We- we didn't kill them very
often, because then you don't
have as many eggs.
And I-- one of my chores was
to gather all the eggs,
which happened daily.
And the family couldn't eat more
than six or eight, ten eggs a
day--
and so we would give them
to neighbors.
And it wasn't like, "I'll give
you this if you give me that."
It was just,
"Here, take some eggs."
And at other times, they'd bring
you milk, if they had a cow.
That's how these uh.. programs
work in the third world
countries...
where they give a family a goat,
and that's not just-- they have
milk...
they get enough milk
for neighbors.
And in that way, they can barter
for other things, and sometimes
even start a small business...
like a little dairy
or something.
is what...and challenges
I think this work
ethic produced.
You had to move on and you had
to.. you had to be creative.
You had to have a creative mind.
Well, things looks pretty
tough...
but it ain't going to be this
way all the time.
The Depression was a
depression...
in a physical, economic sense.
But in the social, and the
cultural, and the spiritual
sense, it was a stimulation.
Struggle and strife and trauma
and tragedy uh..
are great sources of our
greatest strengths...
and one way is that in current
evolutionary thinking...
our basic social tendencies to-
to cooperate, to trust, to uh..
to sacrifice and to give are-
are a product of our collective
sociality...
responding to struggle, and- and
threat, right?
And so when we enter into
historical times where there is
resource deprivation...
or there are threats, it's-- it
turns that on, and people feel
routinely...
you know, in the Great
Depression, or during wartime,
or during, you know, uh..
economic troubles, people feel
immediately this bonding...
tendency that's a great product
of times of-of strife.
Even now, we are not so much
divided as we are disconnected.
If we just could-- power comes
from connection.
Plug it in
and you receive power.
So I enjoy connecting.
I have 106 godchildren...
including the President.
He is one of my godchildren.
106! You know what?
Because I listen. I pray
with them. I talk with them.
I give them directions. We got
to go back to being parents.
My daddy just didn't-- and mama
didn't raise me.
Everybody in my community
raised me!
"I remember you."
You know, but in those days,
people would help each other.
You know, if this person had
something you didn't have, you
know, you--
you'd trade it for it,
or give it to, you know.
And that really brings out
the best in people.
I opened my first official gym
in Oakland in 1936.
See I was the first one to have
women working out with the
weights.
I was the first one to have old
people working out with the
weights.
I was the first one to have
athletes working out with the
weights.
The word got around, "That Jack
LaLanne, he's a nut! He's a
crackpot! You know?
Got women working out with the
weights. Got athletes working
out with them.
The athletes they'll get
muscle-bound. The old guys will
grab a heart attack!"
You can't believe what I went
through! Boy, it was tough!
Not only to open the first gym,
and everything, but then going
through the Depression.
So people had no money, but
that's how I started.
See, I wasn't thinking
of Depression, I was thinking
of helping people.
Up, down, up, down...
is this a racket, I ask you?
Buy low, sell high,
buy low, sell high.
I got a job in 1929 as I just
graduated from high school...
as a messenger at Saloman
Brothers and Hutzler.
I was one of the few people who
got out of Wall Street in
time...
because by September 1st,
I had to go to college.
So I got out of Wall Street and
was out of it for four years.
My f- father was a uh..
insurance broker and agent...
and had a small business with
very few employees and one day,
he came home.
We sat down at dinner and he
said, "I just had to fire
someone...
and it's really upset me
terribly." And at that point,
he broke into tears.
I had never seen my father cry.
Uh.. you know, in those days,
men didn't cry, you know.
You weren't supposed to show
your feeling or what-- all the
nonsense that prevailed.
But I've never forgotten that.
I mean, it upset him terribly
and uh.. that he had to fire...
some-- this man, 'cause-- and he
had to, because he didn't have
the income uh...
you know, to- to pay the salary.
I- it was just-- or else he
couldn't've brought home enough
money to feed us.
In 1945 in November, I came back
from the war and I was in my Air
Force uniform.
Still, I went back home, see my
mother and father.
We were driving around and I
suddenly-- the look in the
corner, the bank...
and there I see Mr. X. And I
said, "Hey, hold it up for a
minute, will ya?"
I was 23 years old and I was
just in great shape.
And I walk into the bank and I
said, "Mr. X, do you remember
me?"
and he said, "No, no. What is
it?" he said, "I'm busy."
And I said, "Oh, just this--
and I spit.
And he stood up, and I hit him,
and it was in-- crazy, it was
just one of those crazy moments.
And I looked around and I was
smiling, and I looked and
everybody was like this.
Nobody moved, nobody stopped me.
He was on the floor.
I said, "That's what you did to
my mother and father."
It was the most satisfying day
of my life, ever, ever.
Still to this day.
There was a- a guy down the
street who had a candy store.
The candy store was always the
center of life and his name
was Joe.
He was a very good looking guy.
Always had a smile on his face.
He wore nice clothes.
And the nice thing about Joe
was, i- if you-- those days the
Daily News was two cents...
and on a-- I think on Sunday it
was a nickel or whatever it was.
And uh.. you came in on Saturday
and you got the Brooklyn
section...
but you didn't have to pay for
the-- for the paper until you
got there on Sunday.
And Joe would always let you
have the Brooklyn section...
assuming that you would get the
rest of the paper on Sunday...
and pay the rest of the money.
So he was like, I don't know,
sweetest man in the world.
One day we woke up, uh.. the
store was closed. What happened?
Joe hung himself.
We always-- I mean, really, I
mean it- it still comes back,
this "why?"
I don't know. Couldn't pay the
rent, whatever it was.
Uh.. those were some of the uh..
things that uh.. happened...
I think uh.. to so many
people at that time.
Everybody had a story.
From the time the United States
entered the era of the
Industrial Revolution...
the early 19th Century, there
were periodic gigantic swings in
the business cycle.
And what were called,
commonly, depressions.
Uh.. in the 1830s, the 1850s,
the 1870s, the 1890s, a pretty
sharp on in 1921...
although it was quite brief.
So the- the Great Depression
of the 1930s is not all that
unfamiliar an episode...
except it's grander in scale,
and lasts longer than the
previous ones.
And there has been nothing
comparable to it since!
You know, it was just an abysmal
event. It was essentially a lost
decade.
I mean, there's a lotta workers
uh.. in their prime working
years that, you know, lost 10...
12, 15 years uh.. of a work
history because of that.
Uhm.. you know, it's almost like
a murder mystery.
You know, we all have our
favorite whodunits um..
and--
and what the Great Depression's
really about, you know,
who killed the economy?
There was a whole generation
of great economists...
who were brought into the
economic profession precisely...
because they perceived that
something had gone very wrong
with our economic system...
and they wanted to understand
what had gone wrong, and
furthermore...
try to figure out how to fix
it...
so that sort of thing
wouldn't happen again.
And the key to preventing a
Great Depression is making your
financial institutions uh...
fireproof, if you like.
Now it used to be we built our
cities entirely of wood.
We crowded everybody together,
and you could have things like
the Great Fire of London...
at the end of the 17th Century,
devastates a huge amount of the
city, and a lot of people...
you know, lose- lose their
belongings and- and many of them
lose their lives.
So you wanna build something
much more like a modern city...
which has different kinds of
structures, more firebreaks...
more firehouses, more fire
engines, uh...
and that's what we wanna do
with our financial system also.
There is no natural process
which updates our regulations.
Uh.. historically, something
goes badly wrong...
and then we recognize that
regulation g- got behind.
You know ,when we have these-
these times of crisis...
you know, it's particularly
important to think about all of
these different dimensions.
And I think that most of the
economic policy debates are
focused on...
how do you deal with regulating
financial markets and so forth.
And that's very important,
but you need to go beyond that
uh...
to, how do you have a more
durable society in which when
crises do happen...
you have a uh.. better safety
net for people's lives.
I- if you're gonna function,
you have to be certain
about some things.
You have to be pretty certain
about who you trust; who loves
you;
where the next meal's gonna come
from and what you're going to do
if it rains.
You have to have that stuff
figured out...
so that you can take risks and
grow and all the other things
that are so much fun to do.
Now when that stuff gets
disturbed, it's physically and
emotionally terrible.
There's a wonderful study that
research teams went around the
country...
doing these in-depth interviews,
and they were trying to discover
all kinds of things...
about how the Depression had
affected people psychologically.
There was one consistent finding
that they found in case after
case after case...
that the unemployed man felt
personally guilty, and
ashamed...
and mortified, embarrassed,
humbled, that he had been put
in this situation.
Now we can look back
historically, and think, "Well,
wait a minute...
this unemployed man we're
talking about here should have
looked around him...
and seen there were 12,999,999
other people unemployed...
and it wasn't that he had
suddenly personally failed,
or lost his moral fiber.
But the reflex of all kinds of
unemployed people...
was to blame themselves for
their situation and not to blame
"the system."
This was an impediment to a
collective political action.
It was something Franklin
Roosevelt remarked repeatedly
to his campaign entourage...
during the presidential
campaign of 1932.
He said, "This is the worst
crisis this country has faced
since the Civil War...
and why aren't people in the
streets? Why aren't they
rioting?
Why aren't they demanding a
political response to this?"
In contradiction to the popular
notion that the population
of America...
was passive for the most
part during the worse days...
of the Great Depression.
The opposite was true.
In Chicago, for example,
among African-Americans...
it was not uncommon in the first
full year of the Depression...
1930, to find hundreds of black
men assembling in Washington
Park...
on the South Side discussing
their plight and what they
should do about it.
In August of 1931, over 1,000
people-- maybe 5,000--
marched on a home where a widow
was about to be set out...
by the police
and the sheriff's bailiffs.
And those thousands of people
prevented her furnishings from
being put on the street.
Unfortunately, uh..
there was a scuffle.
The police drew their weapons,
and killed three of the
demonstrators.
Whites joined blacks in a
massive march down South State
Street...
that had over 30,000 marchers
parade past the funeral home...
where the bodies of the three
deceased lay.
You tie that in,
interracial marches...
with the mid-1930s efforts
of labor unions...
who were organizing in the mass
production industries, and
you've got a- a blending of uh..
interests, and the overcoming--
temporarily at least-- of uh..
past racial tensions.
In the '30s, and this sort of
sets the stage in the north...
for Dr. King being able
to be successful.
We created, in a sense...
parallel institutions, parallel
social institutions...
political institutions,
economic institutions...
cultural institutions, which
gave those of us who were
young...
a feeling that we could
have fun...
and that if we were serious
about the future, we'd go to
school.
Uh.. we- we-- though we were
poor, we were not
poverty-stricken.
And there's a difference. One is
a condition in which you happen
to be...
one is an attitude that one day
things are going to change...
and you're going to be the
beneficiary, if you just
continue, stay out of trouble,
and get the kind of
qualifications-- education and
otherwise--
that will be needed to-
to change your position.
So most of us of that generation
at that time, did that.
I was born in a house close to
the hospital. Segregated
hospitals.
Uh.. segregated graveyards.
So from womb to tomb we faced
segregation.
And that meant not only
separation, it also meant
restrictions...
of access to education, and
healthcare, and jobs, and
development.
So we lived in the shadows
of the Great Depression.
So most blacks during that
period either knew living
grandparents being in slavery.
Or there were many ex-slaves who
were still alive.
So the least educated...
the most vulnerable uh.. had--
took the greatest hit.
And there's a-- it's an
inter-generational continuity.
People who try to slice
and dice...
history miss the fact that God
has not missed one day...
since he started making days.
They're all connected.
So much of the art of the '30s,
literature and visual art is...
is rooted in an interest in
understanding what's happening
during the Depression.
And particularly, you know, at
the outset of it when 25 percent
of Americans were unemployed.
And this is, you know,
this is a huge number...
and had a devastating impact
on people's lives.
And artists were responding to
that impact uh..
even the artists who were
carried over from the 1920s...
like Ernest Hemingway may be the
best example of this.
Hemingway was writing about
individuals during the 1920s and
the problems of individuals.
In the 1930s, he is-- continues
to write these kinds of
stories...
but then he writes a story about
the Spanish Civil War, "For Whom
the Bell Tolls."
And he writes, "To Have and Have
Not," in which--
in which the- the main character
concludes after, you know...
terrible uh.. terrible events
during the novel, "A man alone
doesn't have a chance."
So there's sense of the
collective, the need for other
people to depend upon...
on their fellows is something
that comes up uh.. in- in that
literature...
even in the literature uh.. of
people like Hemingway who came
in from the '20s.
It's very obvious in literature
of Steinbeck, of course, who's,
you know maybe the preeminent...
writer, or the one who
characterizes and in some
ways...
caricatures the whole culture
of the '30s.
One of the few song of that time
that really, at least the
Broadway songs, that- that...
really hits the Depression full
on, I mean, talks about it in no
uncertain terms...
"Brother, Can You Spare a Dime?"
is a very, very powerful song...
written by "Yip" Harburg
and Jay Gorney.
Both were card-carrying
Communists. I don't say that
disparagingly. It's just a fact.
But they were in Central Park
trying to think of a topic for a
song...
and they ran across a man... or
obviously a Harvard educated, an
Ivy League man...
but he was down on his luck. He
was wearing evening clothes, and
he came up to them--
up to them and surprised them
by saying, "Brother, can you
spare a dime?"
And they thought, "That's-
that's the great title." That's
the way the story goes.
But it's a good song in many
ways. Great words, and it refers
back of course to World War I...
it's all about a guy who was a
soldier in World War I, and you
know...
the American government uh..
really did the dirty on--
on the soldiers, the Dough Boys
who'd fought in World War I.
They promised them a bonus at
the end of the war that they
were going to get his money...
and they never gave it to them.
And of course, in the 1930s,
when Hoover was still
President...
we have the famous Bonus Army
marching right the way across
the country...
and setting up their tents
outside the White House.
And the Army actually being
brought in to drive them out...
I mean, physically, violently
dri- drive them out.
But this song directly talks
about those soldiers.
You know, "Ones in khaki suits.
Gee, we look swell, full of that
Yankee Doodle Dum.
Half a million boots went
slogging through Hell.
And I was the kid with the
drum." I like that line.
"Say, don't you remember? They
called me 'Al.'" I mean, that's
a great detail...
"They called me 'Al.'
It was 'Al' all the time.
Say, don't you remember?
I'm your pal. Brother, can you
spare a dime?"
Very powerful song to a minor
key, Eastern European, Jewish
melody.
I mean, very powerful stuff
indeed! But of course, uh..
Harburg went on to write uh..
a piece of, call it fluff, but
certainly an escapist song...
"Somewhere Over the Rainbow," so
uh.. you know, like great--
all great song writers, they can
write all kinds of material.
"Oh, we ain't got a barrel
of money.
Maybe we're ragged and funny.
But we'll travel along, singing
a song, side-by-side."
And you know, people went on to
sing that song v-- in a very
jolly fashion.
But actually the words are- are
very touching, and in fact,
darkly touching.
And the- the verse...
which nobody
knows is, um.. yeah...
"See that sun in the morning,
peeking over the hill?
I bet you know it always has,
I guess it always will.
That's how I feel about someone.
Somebody feels about me.
We know we love each other,
and that's the way it'll
always be."
And then it goes on with the,
"Oh, we ain't got a barrel of
money...
maybe we're ragged and funny.
We'll travel along, singing a
song, side-by-side."
You know, if I have my honey,
you know, we just stick together
and have spunk...
we'll- we'll make it!
And it actually comes out of the
music even more than I ever
realized.
You know, I realize in my shows,
you know, half way in...
I'll let everybody know, "You
know, this got everybody through
the Depression last time!"
Where do ya live?
We moved.
From where?
Uh.. near my aunt's house.
Well, you see, uh.. my aunt
lived a little bit away from
where we used to live.
Uh.. she's a widow.
Her husband died.
That's how she came
to be a widow.
Uh.. the stock market
didn't kill him.
No, he's one that the stock
market didn't kill.
He died in September, BC, before
the crash. Very sick man.
He had diabetes at 45.
That's nothing,
I had Chrysler at 110.
Eddie Canter was uh.. really one
of the people who really changed
our lives.
Because he was on radio Sunday
nights at 8:00.
And uh.. when he got on the air,
during the worst parts of uh..
the Depression...
when people had no jobs, there
was no food on the table...
he would sing like, "Potatoes
are cheaper, tomatoes are
cheaper...
now's the time to fall in love."
He was encouraging people to
fall in love.
Uh.. well that was nice...
but he himself had gone through
a- a very tough time.
He lost his home, he lost his
money, and uh..
they were moving furniture out
of his house...
and he was still able to go on
the radio and start cheering
people up.
For those few minutes that we
saw those guys do their stuff...
uh.. the whole world
was full of hope.
Say, by-cracky, that reminds me
of something I forgot
to remember.
Listen, next time you folks
have to give a present to a
bride and groom...
be sure you make that present
an Aladdin kerosene mantle
lamp.
Now, they can court in the dark
before they get married.
You know, after a while, they
get fed up on it and need a
little light.
Had a letter from a feller says
here he had a falling out with
his gal...
and he- he wrote me he wanted
me to sing, "I only want a
buddy, not a sweetheart."
I'll sing it for him, but I'll
bet a dollar he changes his
mind.
"What is romance, but taking a
chance? Gambling with..."
That's a good example of uh..
early broadcasts.
Now these were called
syndicated shows.
They're 16-inch transcriptions,
uh.. each 15 minutes per side.
And uh.. these were pressed out
by uh...
whoever put them out
for the sponsor.
And they were sent out
to whatever radio stations...
subscribed and- and- and wanted
to play these shows.
And this quite obviously was
very uh..
is aimed at a rural population,
and a population that would be
interested in buying uh..
lamps, because they- they didn't
have electricity at that point.
Uh.. this is a sample of a show
from the Coconut Grove
Orchestra...
here in- in Los Angeles, which
was the preeminent nightclub...
certainly on the West Coast, and
then one of the- the world's,
you know, prominent nightclubs.
Uh.. so here's how the- here's
what the better half would be
listening to, so to speak.
"This enchanting music has
thrilled your favorite star...
and guided their dancing feet
in gay fantasy."
( MUSIC PLAYING )
While out in the farms, some
people had to de- depend on
lamps for their lighting...
here in Los Angeles and other
metropolitan centers...
even during the depths of the
depths of the Depression, uh..
people were still having a good
time, you know?
It was not as though the entire
population was destitute or
anything like that.
You know, it- it- it certainly
affected some people more
than others.
My uncle, by the way, was a
songwriter at that time.
His name was Stanley Demerell.
And he was writing in the depths
of the 1930s Depression in
England.
And he- he wrote songs that were
complete sc- escapism.
One of them is sung today.
He wrote "Lady of Spain, I adore
you," and "Let's All Sing Like
the Birdies Sing."
And he once explained why he
wrote these songs.
He said, "Well," he said,
"my partner and I," he said...
"we- we couldn't compete with
these American, slick American
love songs...
that always seem to take place
on a couch indoors.
So my partner and I decided we
needed to do songs that were
about the outside...
like 'Lady of Spain.'"
And my uncle told me that uh..
things were so bad that...
some of his songwriting
colleagues, and you have to
listen very carefully to this...
um.. some of his colleagues were
forced to pawn, p-a-w-n, their
own underwear.
Which is something, you can't
get much lower than that.
Pawning your underwear.
"Among the rugged peaks that
frown down upon the Borgo
Pass...
are found crumbling castles
of a bygone age."
"Among the rugged peaks that
frown down upon the Borgo
Pass...
are found crumbling castles
of a bygone age."
Hollywood was at that time a
little town...
a little country town.
You know?
And it was wonderful.
I loved it!
The movies kept going.
And uh.. well, people needed
something else, you know...
and to have their minds taken
off their tragedy...
that goes on every day un- until
they get jobs.
It was six cents for children,
and eleven cents for grownups.
There was a penny tax.
And I remember you standing in
front of the theaters...
and when a- an adult would go
in with their 15 cents...
they'd get four pennies back.
And you'd say, "Can I have one
of your pennies, mister, to get
into the movie?"
And they- most people
gave you the penny.
But every now and then, some big
sport would give you four
cents...
so you were well on your way
into the movie.
Of course,
then once you got in...
you opened the door
down at the bottom...
and let two or three
of your friends in.
And then there was a scramble
always, because when you opened
the door, the light...
from the outside... because
they're usually during the of
course it was a matinee
the light from outside would
come in...
and the ushers would come
scrambling to find the kids
who'd just gotten in!
There were the coming
attractions, which we still
have.
That's all we have left of the
way people used to go to the
movies.
Uh.. but when they-- back then
they would see short subjects...
like a comedy short with Laurel
& Hardy.
Uh.. they might see a serial
chapter, you know, a western
that was continued next week.
Uh.. they might see a newsreel.
They would see a cartoon.
Uh.. there were travel logs. You
know, there were all sorts of-
of these subjects...
and uh.. people were just used
to that, seeing a whole
variety...
of different shorts
and then the big picture,
uh.. a full feature.
Movies in the '30s ran the gamut
from extreme poverty row things.
There were guys making westerns
for 900 bucks, you know.
There were big pictures like
"Gone With The Wind" that were
made for multiple millions.
Studios were making 40, 50,
60 pictures a year.
A star could make two, or three
or four films a year, directors
the same.
So today, a filmmaker might make
uh..a film every two or three
years.
Whereas, John Ford in 1939 and
1940 made six, you know, major
classics that uh..
are considered today. "Young Mr.
Lincoln" comes along, "The
Mohawk," "Grapes of Wrath,"
uh.. "How Green Was My Valley?"
"Stagecoach," all within a very
brief span of time.
And of course, the musicals,
too.
You know, "The Gold Diggers
of 1932 then 1933."
And all the girls came out, you
know, all had blonde hair...
and all Busby Berkeley dance
routines. Very glamorous.
And I grew up-- and we all did--
we all grew up with this fantasy
world.
Movies were important.
I saw "Things to Come."
It's a film by H.G. Wells.
It came out in 1936.
And when I saw that film,
I staggered out of that film,
and I said...
"The future's going to belong to
me! I'm going to make the
future."
Oh God, is there never to be any
age of happiness? Is there never
to be any rest?
Rest enough for the individual
man, too much and too soon,
and we call it Death.
But for Man, no rest and no
ending. He must go on, conquest
beyond conquest.
Poor humanity is so fragile, so
weak. Little- little animals.
Little animals.
If we're no more than animals,
we must snatch each little scrap
of happiness...
and live and suffer and pass.
It is this or that.
All the universe or nothingness.
Which shall it be, Passworthy?
Which shall it be?
Well, one of the things I think
that has been misstated about
films of the '30s...
in the past is that um.. the
movies provided escapism.
And it's true, there were a lot
of things like Fred Astaire and-
and musicals and comedies...
W.C. Fields and Bob Hope and the
Marx Brothers provided escapist
entertainment.
What's the show about?
It's all about the Depression.
We won't have to rehearse that.
But there were just as many
films perhaps that--
that dealt with the reality
of the Depression.
But they have not been the ones
that have been revived because
they're--
some of them are pretty grim.
The "Wizard of Oz," the book and
especially the movie...
were also about monetary policy,
about deflation, there not being
enough money.
So the word Oz is short for
ounce, there's the yellow brick
road...
the gold question which was so
salient in that period.
The very dark part in the
beginning, the black and white
part.
That's how people felt about
monetary policy, they knew there
wasn't enough money...
but they also knew, uh.. they
viewed it as like the weather.
There was nothing they could do
about it, it was like a storm
coming.
And they just had to weather it.
The character Dorothy,
she finds her own way.
This disastrous situation,
and she manages sort of, um..
by luck to slay at least one
witch and then another by- by
cleverness.
And she actually manages to uh..
tame the Wizard.
So tame the money.
And that was kind of a fantasy.
verybody points to the '30s
as great golden age...
of the filmmaking process.
But remember that the great
filmmakers of the '30s...
they had learned their craft
in silent films.
The craft
of visual storytelling.
Hitchcock...y mentor, Alfred
saying that with the
advent of sound...
we lost the art form
of the moving image.
When talkies came in, there was
a greater sense of realism.
Silent films had been almost
dreamlike in the way they
presented their stories.
And- and sound brought
a realism to the movies.
And uh.. you saw that manifested
in things like gangster pictures
and backstage dramas.
And you saw more stories about
working-class people...
as well as fantasy-escape things
with- with uh.. rich folks in-
in jeopardy.
How would you feel,
that looks real.
Ah, just a joke,
don't mind them.
Roll all your troubles into a
cigarette...
and puff your blues away.
People expected a cartoon
with their movie show.
You could have-- you could leave
out the newsreel.
You could leave out two-reel
comedy. But you had to have a
cartoon.
In fact, there's a famous 1930s
song that's called, "What? No
Mickey Mouse?
What kind of program is this?"
And that- that was a song that
was popular.
Because it was it was theatre-
theatre didn't show a cartoon.
That's what it was about.
Disney was moving animation from
this, what they call rubber hose
crazy style...
of a- of drawing to a more
realistic style of storytelling.
And all the studios followed
Disney. But in the early '30s,
the depths of the Depression...
those cartoons are particularly
like psychedelic.
They're- they're mind blowing.
Mimi, you funny little good for
nothing Mimi.
Am I the guy?
Mimi, you sunny little honey
of a Mimi.
There was no- no realism here.
And the stories themselves are
sort of--
these guys were just making it
up as they went along.
Storytelling even as in a short
cartoon wasn't sophisticated...
as it would be 10 years later...
when they made Bugs Bunny
cartoons and Daffy Duck
cartoons.
In this early '30s period, uh..
they might start the story in
one place...
and go outside and then suddenly
they're going somewhere else.
They would just come up with
these stores, and they would
just, uh..
kinda draw them, you know, uh..
free form, you know, stream
of consciousness.
That's how they look.
My first paycheck is from--
really, paycheck is from uh...
Walt Disney Studio.
I was on "Bambi"
for three and a half year.
So that was- that was ideal.
They didn't pay me very much,
but then I loved the job.
Going back to the WPA...
I remember S. Macdonald,
Stanton Macdonald-Wright.
He was the director.
I brought my painting in there
and showed it to him.
So we got paid $96 per month...
So you turn- turn in two oil
paintings...
and two watercolor
or else four lithographs.
So that's like, getting through
the WPA, that's a good thing.
That saved a lot of artists
from starving to death.
Narrator: The sensitive fingers
of artists are poorly suited to
manual labor.
And in finding suitable work
for musicians and other
artists...
the WPA has contributed greatly
to the culture of America.
Painters, too, contribute their
bit to making the works
program...
a real and permanent
accomplishment.
These reproductions of the
American scene of today...
will make this one of the most
fertile periods of our
country's art.
( MUSIC PLAYING )
Some of this work is done on
canvas...
but much of it is created on the
walls of our schools...
libraries and other public
buildings in the form of mural
paintings.
The fact that the government
would experiment...
with the idea of putting
creative people to work and...
and getting a public good out
of it uh...
was really piloted here
at Coit Tower in San Francisco.
That really was the pilot
program that had helped to
launch the WPA...
the Works Progress
Administration's use of artists.
So the 26 artists who got
involved and were
commissioned...
to create these murals here at
Coit Tower were really uh.. the
pioneers.
The sort of-- the experiment
that worked.
And then it allowed public art
to spread across the whole
country.
It's a school of art called
social realism, and uh...
that's most of what's depicted
in these murals.
And social realism was really
about capturing everyday life...
and helping to tell the story
of the average person, um...
as opposed to just what,
you know the--
the news and the media sort of-
would sort of highlight, back
then, and even today...
which is the story of the great
man, right?
The- the captains of industry.
And there is a- a- an
opportunity of creating
community...
when you deal with a lot
of public art.
And that's certainly been the
philosophy of many of the
murals...
that we have been commissioned
by the Arts Commission over the
years here in San Francisco.
We are at Lucy Flower High
School, and this is the foyer
of the school...
and this mural was created
between 1938 and 1940 by Edward
Millman.
He was an artist
that was on the WPA.
And he wanted to create a mural
about outstanding American
women.
And at the same time, he was
studying a lot about the Mexican
muralist movement.
And prior to creating this, he
had actually gone to Mexico...
and studied with Diego Rivera
in 1934.
So when he was sort of building
the agenda for this image...
he wanted to really promote that
kind of social realism...
within this sort of temple
that you see here.
It took him two years to
complete uh.. this image.
And then one year later, it was
deemed by the Board of
Education...
as misery-laden and depressing.
So they whitewashed
it one year later.
This image is probably the most
controversial in the city
of Chicago...
because it was so heavy.
And it was talking about so many
core truths...
to what was happening
at the time.
thing to remember is...rtant
artists are like a barometer
of what's happening.
They record what's going on,
they tell these stories in
creative and imaginative ways.
And when that kind of
philosophical and intellectual
creativity is covered up...
that's- that's something that
is really hard to take.
So when you walked into this
room, it was completely white
in 1996.
And so we did test after test to
try to figure out how to unveil
this powerful image.
It was a pretty magical time
for us. That was in 1997.
And it took us about nine months
to move throughout this entire
room...
and then we had an unveiling
ceremony.
And it was all about unveiling
the history that it
encapsulated.
So yes, it was very precious
to all of us involved.
And remains so.
And one of the main themes that
emerges in- in- in the arts of
the '30s...
and the whole culture of the
'30s, is- is the one that
Hemingway...
eventually comes to that the
individual alone doesn't
have a chance.
And so this idea that people
need other people...
that the individual can be
broken, but then maybe stronger.
But- but- but so much of the-
of- of the art of the period was
moving toward a sense...
and- and the politics
of the period...
moving toward a sense
of necessity politically
for empathy, for care...
for, you know, brotherhood,
for collective action...
whether it's in strikes or in,
you know, the implementation
of a Social Security system.
At the same time, it's also
strongly resisted by- by- by
uh...
a whole other, you know,
political set.
So- so the '30s becomes a really
polarized period politically...
you know, between uh.. you know,
between these collectivist
notions...
and the notions of- of the
individual that are still fairly
strong um...
in- in this country.
( MUSIC PLAYING )
( APPLAUSE )
You and you and you and you
you've got a President now.
He gave the land a new deal! You
hold the cards, now you deal.
You and you and you and you put
shoulders to the plow.
He gave us what we asked for,
now pay him back somehow!
Step out in front,
get back of the President.
And give a man a job.
Franklin Roosevelt's achievemenT
is all the more remarkable...
because he had not only to
invent the tools with which to
fight the Depression...
but he had to convince people
that it was legitimate to do
anything at all.
And there were a lot of people
who were very, very skeptical...
that there was anything that
should be done here other than
just let the thing go down...
the drain, and eventually it
would take care of itself.
There was a woman named Lorena
Hickok that was employed by the
Roosevelt administration...
to go around the country and
write reports about how
people...
were dealing with the economic
difficulties.
And, you know, what- what she
really came to say in--
and especially like in the Farm
Belt and- and different parts of
the country...
is that she saw this kind of
prevailing sense of despair.
You know, people were becoming
apathetic, you know?
And- and I- I think to a certain
extent, you know, "The New
Deal"...
did play a role in kind of
letting people know, you know...
we're not going to let things
continue in- continue on as
they- as they have been.
You know, we are going to try
and improve the situation.
And I think that meant a lot
to a lot of people.
Well, I remember sitting
by the radio...
whole family sitting by the
radio listening to a fireside
chat, you know, Roosevelt.
PRESIDENT ROOSEVELT:
To assert my firm belief...
that the only thing we have
to fear is fear itself!
I want my money!
Let go of the bank!
Let me get my money!
Doctor! Doctor!
Doctor!
There's your Doctor.
( HAIL TO THE CHIEF PLAYING )
Mr. President, what will
cure a Depression?"
Confidence can lick
this old Depression!
Confidence, hey, hey!
It's our salvation!
Preach it, tout it,
shout it!
Confidence!
Just have confidence!
Wake up, wake up
Open up the door
Hey there I know
We'll come back with more
Yesterday there were skies of
Gray but today is another day
Go worm go worm
We'll all get a break
New day's dawning
For worker and dawn
No more bumming
We'll all get to work
There's a new day dawning now
I'll think we'll win out.
Not because of a government,
not even because of our leaders.
But because as a people,
we've had a vision...
and we've worked for it
and we've seen it through.
Thank you.
The President of the United
States, inspired by the way...
by his wife, Eleanor, uh..
at least, no- I'd say
inspired...
directed by Eleanor...
tended to want to give
to the community...
greater opportunities
then they had enjoyed.
I pledge myself to a New Deal
for the American people!
It opened thoughts...
opportunities about
out of the New Deal...
can we begin to create
a real deal?
Some people felt that FDR was
the closest thing to keeping us
from getting--
having a revolution
in this country.
In other words, he was providing
work with the WPA and all these
different projects...
that if that wouldn't have
happened there are those who
contended...
we would have had a bloody
revolution.
So you had a lot of social
unrest at that time.
Not like it was necessarily over
in Europe, but you had people
that were out of work.
They were hungry. They- they
looked at fascism or
communism...
and that gave them- that gave
them a chance, an opportunity
maybe to climb up the ladder.
Maybe there's something wrong
with our system. Maybe we ought
to do that.
So you- you saw that even at
that time as a youngster.
I remember arguments between my-
my father and other people about
political things like that.
Dealing not so much about
Washington politics...
but what the situation would
have to be-- we'd have to go the
European route.
In other words, either fascism
or communism, because that's the
way to do things right.
The- the New Deal, for all
of its historical consequence...
it failed to end
the Great Depression.
But it did something else, and
it did something I think that
was part of a very high level...
visionary, political calculus
that Roosevelt had in mind.
It used the moment of this
enduring crisis to put in place
a set of major reforms...
of institutional rearrangement
of the whole social and economic
landscape...
that stabilized the economy once
it recovered with World War
II...
and provided the latticework
or the scaffolding on which
the American economy...
and indeed the international
economy, uh..
grew like crazy for a half
century after World War II.
You're always going
to have boom and bust.
You don't want-- and you even
have panics to some degree...
but you- you don't want those
to become big Depressions...
meaning output goes down quite
a lot and then stays down,
and you struggle to recover.
You lose a decade.
You can lose a decade!
And we know from the Japanese
experience recently...
it can happen even today in
relatively rich countries.
So I-I don't think there should
be any presumption that we've
grown out of depressions.
Right? Maybe we've learned some
things about how to avoid them;
maybe we haven't.
But I think that- that's what
the discussion should really
focus on.
It was crisis, it was meltdown.
We feared that all the financial
sector, uh... banks and security
firms may go down.
The Lost Decade is a period...
of e- extremely low economic
growth for the Japanese economy.
So the business were not uh..
doing very well in general.
The sort of norm was that after
you graduated from the
college...
and you uh... you go
for a large firm.
And a large firm
will keep you for life.
So you are on the track, and you
can plan your- your life at the
age of 22.
That was the sort
of typical picture.
Because of the lifetime
employment system, they cannot
fire the core workers.
So what the many Japanese
companies did during the Lost
Decade of the 1990's...
is to keep the core employees...
to keep the workers on the
lifetime employment system...
but stopped hiring.
So the first hit was not the
company employees...
but the fresh out of college.
They couldn't find, you know,
the- this- this famous uh...
lifetime uh... employment.
We made a lost generation.
Belonging to some community
organization...
it might be family
or company or school...
whatever, is very important.
Very important.
And uh.. actually company,
corporation, did a very
important thing.
Japanese companies,
companies are heavily
in charge of the uh..
sustaining many social security
or social importance,
practically.
Rather than government itself.
But uh.. you know, the lost
generation didn't have a chance
to--
to belong to that kind of,
you know, community.
Stability of the society,
or stable healthy growth...
or development of the society,
we have to rebuild that kind
of community.
So that's really our
challenge...
that the answer is not getting
back- simply getting back to any
old system.
We have to rebuild the concept
of the corporation.
We- we have to rebuild the
concept of the employment or
labor.
So that's really a real
challenge.
So we really need just sort of
distractive, I mean, creation.
What we can clearly see now is
to avoid what happened in Japan,
to avoid a lost decade here in
the United States...
which at this point may or may
not be unavoidable...
um, really, honestly, is that we
need a massive injection...
a continued massive injection
of economic stimulus.
The question is, "Where is this
going to come from?"
The economy has four basic areas
that we have um.. that drive
economic growth.
In the United States, about 70
percent of economic growth comes
from consumers.
Well, consumers have declining
home values, declining stock
portfolios...
one in ten of them nearly
is out of a job.
So that's really not going to be
a place where we're going to see
a lot of demand growing...
in the- in the short
to medium term.
Until the- until jobs come back,
consumption is not going to
drive our economy forward...
it's not where we're going to
see our recovery.
And that's 70 percent
of our economy...
so we've got to make up for that
big chunk someplace else.
The other three places we can
look to are business
investment...
export growth,
and government spending.
Businesses aren't going to
invest until they see consumers.
So there's a little bit
of chicken and egg problem
going on there.
Exports are up a little bit...
but still it's a relatively
small share of our overall
economy...
so it's not clear how that- that
relatively small share can pull
the whole US economy out.
And then the last place we can
look is in terms of government
spending...
to create economic demand.
That's exactly what we did
during the Great Depression.
And it's something that we
haven't really needed in uhm..
in the same way that we need it
now or any point since the Great
Depression.
( INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC PLAYING )
I think we progress in lurches.
I think we lurch forward.
I think we adopt a set of rules
and a vocabulary...
and a standard for truth, and
that serves us well, this is
certainly true in science.
It serves us well right up until
the moment where all of a
sudden...
it isn't working,
and the whole world comes apart.
We don't know how to change it
gradually.
We just have to wait
for the iceberg.
And then a wonderful thing
happens. The world falls apart.
And we are able to stand there
and say...
"What are we really trying to do
here?" What is our world really
like?
And one of our most important
resources in this country
is our creativity.
You know, and- and that- and
that if we can really kind of
deploy that, you know...
I- I think in many respects the
answers to kind of working
ourselves out...
of these economic troubles may
not come from that, you know,
the Congress or you know...
or you know, the House of
Representatives or, you know...
big corporations
or the Federal Reserve.
But it may be something, you
know, things that go on in
people's garages, you know?
Things like sustainable living
tips, you know, alternative
currencies.
We're going to see a lot
of things happening on the
ground...
that are going to be kind
of important innovations.
We're- we're-- I- I think it's
kind of an inborn American
trait...
that we have a tendency to kind
of tinker and innovate...
when we're not happy with
existing or outdated systems.
If you look historically,
a lot of strong businesses...
were started during a- a
downturn in the economy...
during the Great Depression,
or other recessions we've had.
But, I mean, I was an investment
banker working 90 hours a
week...
I'd- I'd never have the time to
launch something like that.
Well, once I got laid off,
schedule opened up.
And I thought, "Well, now is as
good a time as any."
All jobs seem to be so hard
to get now...
that I think you're seeing
people really just go after
where their passions are...
as opposed to, "Well, this is
where the money is."
So I think you're seeing a
number of paradigm shifts...
more so than before in value--
shift in values, I think.
And- and I-- my hope is that
they'll last, uhm.. so that
we'll have--
that there'll be more of a gap
between these- these boom and
bust periods.
And so we'll see. People tend to
have short memories, I think...
particularly when times
do start to turn around.
Welcome to New York City,
financial capital of the world.
Welcome to Wall Street, the
heart of American capitalism.
I was a former Vice President
at Deutsche Bank.
There I helped manage a billion
dollar trading business.
The crisis displaces a lot of
people. You know, I lost my job.
You know, It's Adam Smith,
invisible hand...
smacking me around and putting
me into a different area of the
economy.
But uh.. for me, you know, I'm-
I'm really happy with what I'm
doing now.
Showing people Wall Street.
Telling my story.
I love to teach.
Some people uh.. find
inspiration.
You know, it's-- they're saying,
"Hey, here's a guy making
lemonade out of lemons."
You know, other people say...
"You know, hey, here's a trader
that's been downgraded to a tour
guide," you know?
It's two different ways
to look at it.
Two years ago I was fully
infiltrated in the financial
industry...
which I loved and adored,
and had been doing since
I graduated from college.
And as time passed, I started to
see everything going on in the
financial markets...
just huge blowups.
I then, in fact, got my pink
slip, and ended up being laid
off.
And I often remember my mom
saying like the farm...
is what saved her parents
during the Depression.
They also did like crazy stuff
like, you know, sell moonshine,
I guess.
And you know, like house
different um.. people coming
over from Europe...
that needed extra housing and
put them up.
Um.. but always kind of like
thinking of different ways
of uhm..
being smart and making money
and- and saving their money.
I worked really hard in finance,
but I'm working a lot harder
now...
than I ever worked in finance,
you know, for- for nothing,
basically, you know.
Hopefully to potentially attain
something...
but it's a return to
intelligence and creativity and,
you know...
this emergence of young
entrepreneurs, with socially
conscious types of businesses.
We're all kind of like bartering
with one another of how to get
work done, and how to, you know,
get a fashion show done
with no capital.
"Well, this person needs this
exposure, and I need this."
"And let's like figure out a way
to make this happen."
So yeah, it's an interesting
time, and it's--
it's also like something great
to be a part of, I feel.
Fang, my husband, Fang, uh..
was so cheap that once he took
the kids and me out...
for coffee and donuts.
The kids loved it, because they
had never given blood before.
What a joke.
That's a beautiful joke.
In retrospect, it may look like
a great thing that happened...
that was a necessity to get us
back on the track properly.
Because after all...
we, each of us are a part
of human evolution.
And we take with us technology.
And we're speeding
into the universe.
Your experience that you had
coming through those times
sustain you.
They make you strong, you're
tested in a crucible of a fire.
The Depression beat people down.
So there's wonderful and
romantically to say...
"Look at how these people pulled
themselves up and made something
of themselves."
But there's also that other half
of the population that couldn't
do that.
That were so beaten down by the
Depression that it a- affected
their mindset...
and people around them, and
their families, for- for years
and years to come.
So unless you have that
courage to keep on...
and those early days in the
Depression days molded a lot
of people.
They gave them the courage and
the strength to become somebody.
I would not say it makes us
stronger. I would say it
makes us free.
It makes us more confident
when it's all over.
It makes us confident in our
ability to survive.
That part of it is true.
But it doesn't make our
beliefs stronger.
It usually destroys them.
It doesn't make our family
systems stronger, it usually
injures them.
It doesn't make our economic
system stronger or our political
system stronger...
it usually wrecks it.
So I don't think in those senses
that it made us stronger.
I think what it did was force us
to think freely and anew about
our lives.
And the way we're going to judge
truth, the way we communicate to
each other.
trust and not trust.ling to
I think it's a moment
of enlightenment.
Now, it's usually accompanied
by nausea.
We're so often saved in spite
of ourselves, you know?
There's- there's something
Arnold Toynbee, a great
historian...
said that his lifelong study
of-- and he was no mystic.
He was a very practical man.
He said his lifelong study
of history had led him
to the conclusion...
that every time the puddle of
human affairs was about to
congeal completely...
the finger of God comes down
and stirs it.
And I thought,
"It seems like that sometimes!"
One of the beauties of that
period was that though we had no
money of any large--
except for that small upper five
or six percent of the
population...
who were jumping out of windows
or committing suicide because
they couldn't take it--
we had ways to take it.
And that, again, is the factor
that is a part of American life
and American dream...
is that we can take it because
it's going to get better!
( INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC PLAYING )